[Music]
Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth heat
things up on the beach I really don't
think there's anyone hotter the Malibu
singer and her actor beau hit the sand
in Byron Bay Australia recently
flaunting their love and their killer
bodies thank you very much the 25 year
olds kept it casual in a baseball hat a
black cheeky bikini and itty-bitty denim
cutoffs while Liam soaked up the Sun in
a pair of shades and colourful swim
trunks I don't only like Beyonce that
pimps their fiancee out like talk about
a hot they are the couple met while
playing love interests in the 2010 movie
the last song was made me feel like you
do right got engaged in 2012 I'm really
happy to be engaged split the following
year but rekindled their relationship in
2016
reconfirming their engagement by october
ET recently caught up with elsa Pataki
who is married to Liam's big bro Chris
Hemsworth and she gushed about her
future sister-in-law we love it because
she's so actually she's just so creative
that from any moment on every
circumstances she actually just writes
ups writes a song so we'll love her and
I have a new hair around it's good
because we are like it's just giving it
time just sing something and she doesn't
she's amazing she has my my kids love
her because she has an amazing voice
[Music]